hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast I'm your host Sean
Carroll those of you who are Game of
Thrones fans and remember the finale
earlier this year mostly not a success
in my eyes and those are some others but
there were some good moments in there
there's a quote I remember from Tyrion
when he says there's nothing in the
world more powerful than a good story
you hear quotes like that quite often in
fiction and you know maybe a little
self-serving since these are words
written by storytellers who are
basically telling us through the mouths
of their characters there are no people
more powerful in the world than us but
still I'm sympathetic to the quote you
know there are individual people who do
things people who have more power
instruments of power whether
technological or otherwise but these are
often motivated by the stories people
are telling themselves and each other
about why they're here why they're
acting in certain ways and a wonderful
person to comment on the role of stories
in our culture in our world is today's
guest Stephen Greenblatt
he's the Jon Cogan University professor
of humanities at Harvard and a very
well-known Shakespeare scholar and
literary historian he's one of the
founders probably the main driving force
between the New Historicism school of
literary criticism that takes both the
literary texts and also its context and
the historical resonances altogether as
part of the analysis of that text so
Shakespeare has been Stephen
Greenblatt's main focus of research over
the years but he's also won the Pulitzer
Prize in the National Book Award for a
book on Lucretius the book is called the
swerve how the world became modern and
Lucretia's of course is one of my
favorite ancient poets author of darrell
naturae on the nature of things which
tells a cosmological story for ancient
atomists who didn't want to just give
God all the credit for everything and
Greenblatt has also written about Adam
and Eve the origin story of the
Christian and Hebrew Bibles so this is a
wonderful opportunity to talk about how
we think about the world which is
something we do a mindscape every week
but in the context of the stories that
we tell about the world
is what we're doing all the time whether
we know it or not so let's go
[Music]
speaking Greek laughs welcome to the
mindscape podcast thanks
pleasure to be here we don't usually
have Shakespeare scholars on the podcast
but you've written a book about the book
of Genesis about Adam and Eve in that
story and also a book about Lucretia's
who wrote this wonderful poem about the
the universe back in ancient time so I
begin to get the feeling that maybe
you're secretly desiring to be a
cosmologists I'm not cosmologists but I
am interested in the origins of things
the origins of the world that we live in
of the ideas that we have and I'm
particularly interested in the role that
the human imagination has played in our
fashioning a world for ourselves yeah
and I think you know since the audience
is probably not used to topics like this
when we just start with the very biggest
picture and you know when you're at
cocktail parties or stuck in airplanes
and people say explain to me what you do
but how do you explain the role of a
literary scholar I I don't I'm not at
cocktail parties that often people don't
invite me to explain what I do very
often but I suppose if they do I say I'm
a writer and literary historian I
sometimes say I'm a Shakespearian mm-hmm
since that covers a lot of ground but
not as you say all the ground and if you
ask what a literary scholar does it's in
general to try to immerse themselves in
and their students in this astonishing
thing that survived that continues to
survive from human beings which is that
that we over a long period of time
actually from the beginning as a species
have tried to register and leave traces
of our experience which is an odd thing
to do I mean other animals in general
don't do that so already
35,000 years before the present people
drew things on the walls of caves and
recorded what they thought or dreamt
that they thought around them and they
also signed those objects as you may
know by putting their hands up against
the walls of caves
and blowing blowing the pigment around
them so you see these handprints if you
have to go to those astonishing caves so
if the the you know the little thing
that says Picasso or Rembrandt is a very
old idea and and and in addition again
if we're going to stay there since we're
starting to talk about origins and
cosmology I suppose in those same caves
archaeologists have found flutes made
out of bare bone so that obviously that
the red the creation of music goes back
basically to the beginnings of what it
means to be almost sapiens so we have
art we have music and then in the oldest
of the caves I mean the oldest of the
surviving ones that we know in in France
there's from the very beginning in that
case there's a figure very few human
figures but in that instance as a
there's a figure that is the legs of a
woman and then the head of a bull and if
we who knows what that means but if we
it among other things what it has to
mean is that is that something that we
would call myth making a storytelling
also goes back to the beginnings Homo
sapiens aren't that old as a species so
this is the very or these are among the
earliest traces we have of our species
life so we have we have art and music
and storytelling and to be a literary
critic or to be interested in any case
in the humanities or the arts is to be
interested in this fundamental series of
things that we do as a species and it's
interesting you went to ancient history
right away I mean sort of your angle
here has been what has been called New
Historicism or I guess you have called
it cultural poetics the I don't even
want to try to define it but maybe you
can put it into words
bringing together the the history and
context of things with the text
themselves so the
first thing to say Shawn is that that
whatever newest tourism or cultural
products is the first thing to say is
that the reason I go back to the
beginning is that the humanity is unlike
let's say neuroscience or geology or or
medical treatments this there's no
charting of a history of progress and
that's very strange we have to take in
how strange that is if I go to a doctor
I don't actually want to be treated with
with the therapies that were current in
1980 and I certainly don't want me
treated with the therapies that were
current in 1680 so that that we actually
do sometimes we're deceived or something
disappointed but we expect that there's
some kind of history of progress but in
the case of the arts if you go to the
caves that lets go you absolutely you
wouldn't say that those paintings are
better than then
broy galore Rembrandt but you but you
also would be very hard pressed to say
they're worse yeah they can hang with
our president in days that's astonishing
weird I think how weird that is and so
the the first thing to say putting
whatever approach you have aside is that
the there's no clear history of progress
there are individual little histories of
progressed there are progressions within
technologies representational
technologies but there's no history of
progress and I think we have to let that
especially in our current culture we
have to actually take in how odd that is
and one of the things that it means is
that we can be in strangely intense and
direct contact with people who lived a
very long time ago in circumstances and
places that we can barely understand and
in cultures that we have almost no other
access to I say that way because it puts
the project of historicism putting newer
stars as an aside it puts the project as
historicism in the peculiar light
you could say that historicism
traditionally the historical study of
the humanities has tried to recreate the
and understand and and explore the
cultural historical social circumstances
that led to the production of the works
of art that we care about but and I
think that's important insofar as you
can do it but you a you can't always do
it and B so what what if you do it you
have to start in my view with the other
thing which I've talked about the
astonishment that we can still be in
touch with this without actually almost
any contextual understanding whatsoever
it's as if we found a random yellowed
letter in the desk in the city in the
hotel in the city that we've never been
in before and we opened the letter and
it's addressed to us by someone who's
been dead for hundreds of years so take
that in and start there the trouble with
oldest tourism is that it tended to
suppress that fact I think that's weird
fact about our encounter with the ghosts
of the past however the other side of
this encounter is that we can even if we
can't think about what's moving us are
reaching us
from the history of culture of the past
that take one of those caves for example
where we have almost no understanding of
what that culture was like our only the
most rudimentary and primitive
understanding we actually know something
about ourselves and we can think a
little bit about why we're responding so
powerfully the thing so what it's
speaking to in us hence the new and
newest or system that we start to think
about the historical circumstances or
the social and cultural circumstances
insofar as we can understand them of the
past but only in relation to what we're
feeling in here now to the questions
that we're asking to who we are I say
that because because all the historical
work in the world done by people like me
and people much smarter than me trying
to understand
what Shakespeare or Homer or Joyce or
anyone was about that produced these
astonishing works that kind of
historical explanation can never answer
magically the power of those works the
works reach you independent as it were
of the historical understanding but it
remains fascinating to try to grapple
with the with the meanings of the past
with how these works were produced and
above all how works that were not
produced in our world still address us
well I mean it's interesting because
what you seem to be emphasizing there is
the a history of some of these texts in
the sense that there there is a
universal aspect to them to the good
ones anyway maybe well at the very least
I would say I start with saying yes the
funny thing about the new and newer star
system is it also is a slightly anti
mysticism it's against the the idea that
used to be carried when you said look
you don't understand anything unless you
go back into the past and understand
what the circumstances are I mean I'm
very sympathetic to that account but I
think that it has great limits and the
other side of what I'm saying is that
there is a history that we do have
access to and it's our history and that
to to be aware of our history and to
bring it to bear on whatever historical
traces we're encountering seems to me
part of the project I pulled down a book
when we were getting ready for this
interview because I thought this
question would come up and I wanted to
suggest how it works yeah so a very long
time ago
1980 I published a book called
Renaissance self-fashioning and even
before then I had written this this
particular the particular passage I'm
looking at about Shakespeare's
contemporary Christopher Marlowe and
about the strange violent and disturbing
imagination of Marlowe and the works
that he produced in the 1580s for his
late fifties for his contemporaries
but in the beginning of this chapter in
this old book of mine called Renaissance
self-fashioning
I begin the following way on June 26th
1586 a small fleet financed by the Earl
of Cumberland set out from Gravesend for
the South Seas it sailed down the West
African coast citing Sierra Leone in
October and at this point we may let one
of those on board the merchant John
Sarah call tell his own story and what
follows is a quotation which I'll read
the fourth of November we went on shore
to a town of the Negros which we found
to be but lately built lately recently
built it was of about two hundred houses
and walled about with mighty great trees
and stakes so thick that a rat could
hardly get in or out but as a chanced we
came directly upon a port which was not
shut up where we entered with such
fierceness that the people fled all out
of the town which we found to be finally
built after their fashion and the
streets of its so intricate that it was
difficult for us to find the way out
that we came in that we found their
houses and streets so finally and
cleanly kept that it was an admiration
to us all for that neither in the houses
no streets with so much dust to be found
as would fill an eggshell we found
little in their houses except some mats
gourds and some earthen pots our men at
their departure set the town on fire and
it was burned for the most part of it in
a quarter of an hour the house is being
covered with reed and straw okay that's
the passage and I go on to talk about
Marlowe's plays and about the strange
current of violence in in Marlowe's work
the peculiar blend of almost
incomprehensible admiration and violence
and so on and so on and wave opening up
place like Tamburlaine that and dr.
Faustus and so forth but the reason I
read the passage is that probably not
for you and probably not for most of
your listeners but for me
and for my generation that passage which
comes from the past had a very specific
resonance when this was published in
1980 and when I wrote the essay back in
the 70s and the resonance has to do with
a scene that had burned its way into our
consciousness which was shown on
television CBS I think when Morley Safer
was then a young reporter recently died
after a distinguished career as a
reporter was in Vietnam and did a famous
show the famous clip it was only a few
minutes or less of a GI setting fire to
a Vietnamese village with their straw
roofs with his Zippo lighter famous
scene where they kind of meaningless a
random act of violence against people
who are non-combatants so newest star
sysm my work and the work to some extent
of other sudden my generation had to do
yes with excavating the past but
excavating the past is never neutral
activity it has something to do with
what we're interested in who we are so
why this passage from John's era call
out of if you actually look I don't have
it in this office where we're having
this conversation but if you look at
Hackett's voyages there's volume after
volume after this huge bodies of this
and I'm I was a particularly at this
point of my life a mad reader of those
things just a kind of crazy
grazer into the past that way and I
always trusted my unconscious if that's
what it was when I would read and read I
would suddenly think think here stop
what is this why is this reaching me
from this enormous body of things that
traces that survived from the past and
that passage from ser call is a perfect
example we're just out of the enormous
randomness I wasn't particularly
interested in Sierra Leone or the Earl
of Cumberland or this a virtually
anonymous merchant but suddenly
something left off the page for me and I
asked myself why is it leaping off the
page for me and it was both because it
spoke to my present and because it
seemed to be a key that unlocked a door
in Christopher Marlowe's work it's not
stuck there in the past right we
recently just had Columbus Day a few
weeks ago and there's no ongoing
argument about how to think about that
part of the pattern I was flabbergasted
by though I don't know if you read this
is another piece of of the historicism
member of a curious kind I didn't know
this before but I didn't know about the
origins of Columbus Day which is a one
time it was meant as a one time event by
the president Benjamin Harrison I didn't
know instituted it in the wake of the
lynching in New Orleans of 11 southern
Italians who had been who had been
exonerated in the trial accused of some
nefarious crime or other and then a
crowd gathered caught them and lynched
them and the lynching was actually in
this article about it was weirdly
approved of even by northern newspapers
like the New York Times
why because southern Italians at that
point particularly southern Italians
were perceived as black and were treated
the way in the sort of mass murder mode
of America and racism the way blacks
were treated so Columbus Day originated
if you think of it from that perspective
as a as an attempt to make Italians
white southern Italians white at the
expense of course of the war you could
say at the expense of blacks I mean of
African Americans I mean that the to try
to create the boundary around those whom
it was okay to Lynch I can imagine I
never knew that I mean that I was I was
quite astonished by this as an article
in The New York Times that ran around
Columbus Day he speaks these elusive of
remembering some of that history
let me pause for a second to talk about
quip electric toothbrushes I know there
are people out there probably in this
audience who actually enjoy brushing
their teeth and generally keeping up
with good dental hygiene I'm someone who
has to be coerced into doing it I
understand the benefits of it it's
crucially important really but I need a
little nudge and the nice thing about
quip is it makes it easy to have good
dental hygiene the electric toothbrush
which is the centerpiece of the system
is very pleasant to use very ergonomic
very stylish industrial design and it
has an automatic timer that lets you
know when you've been rushing for two
minutes which believe it or not is how
much you're supposed to brush every day
but also every three months they're
gonna give you toothpaste floss and a
fresh brush head and if you go to get
quip comm slash mindscape right now
you'll get your first refill free that's
your first refill free at get quip comm
slash mind escapes spelled GE T Q u IP
dot-com slash mind scape quip is the
good habits company I guess you point
out the idea that we can't understand
text in the past unless we dive into
their history that's probably wrong
that's probably too far but then there's
the other idea that these texts are just
supposed to be understood as works of
art in some pure realm of aesthetic
beauty and I if I remember correctly
you'll probably don't remember this
better than I do but in the 80s and 90s
your name was invoked in the culture
wars right when people were talking
about the tempest and whether or not you
should think of it as telling us
something about colonialism somehow and
there were people who thought like oh no
no that's not yes that's not how we
should be thinking about Shakespeare
yeah I had a brief moment of notoriety
because George Williams actually is a
sort of interesting figure I mean but
often quite I think thoughtful wrote
something that said that that people who
like me who said that the tempest was
actually about colonialism were more
dangerous than sad on us Hussein that
was a very implausible thing to say but
this result
passions of the moment look two quick
things about the work of art as pure
beauty of course it's not true I mean
works of art are embedded in particular
moments like everything is embedded I
mean take place and make statements and
and have influences on the other hand
the idea that works of art don't matter
or that they're works of pure beauty or
that they they have no relation to the
society has served art well in various
circumstances for example in Oh in
repressive regimes that have allowed
works of art to to say things that would
be punished elsewhere so a work the idea
that works of art are not engaged in
political or social work but are are
purely about beauty is itself an
historical or cultural and political and
political phenomenon with an enormous
importance at various moments in 1610
the English authorities under James the
first decided to caught and decided to
kill a Welsh Catholic a Benedictine
named I think his last name was Roberts
John Roberts maybe who was very popular
worked with the poor and was it had a
kind of charismatic following and the
state in its general hostility to
Catholics which extended through the
late 16th and early 17th century decided
to kill this guy and when they had the
execution they did the usual unspeakable
things and then they took his heart the
executioner took his heart out of his
chest held it up before the crowd and
said here's the heart of a traitor long
live the king
crowd was completely silent so we know
about this because this was the crowd
silence was surprising and upsetting
from the point of view of the
authorities because they authorities
suspected the crowd would shout god save
the king so if you if you said anything
other than God saves the king you could
be in tremendous trouble in a
circumstance of that kind and the the
authorities of the time watched very
carefully how the crowd was responding
in events of this kind same year 1610
The Winter's Tale Shakespeare's Winter's
Tale is performed before 3,000 people
and then afternoon and in the theatre in
London and a character the the
tyrannical King says to a woman
character named Paulina who's enraged
him I'll have you burned and she says
it's a heretic that makes the fire not
she which burns in it now if someone
said anything of the kind at that
execution
it's a heretic that's making the fire
there's a heretic that's that's
executing the man not this guy is not
heretic there's this victim if someone
said that at the at the scene of the
execution or if someone said that in a
tavern they would have their ears cut
off the tongue cut out or they'd be
killed but a character could say this
before three thousand people on an
afternoon and the night of the actor nor
the playwright nor the company got in
trouble for it why because it's a work
of art I mean doesn't mean anything it
doesn't have any political life a minute
sit now that's what people I think what
what I try to make people understand
which is that that saying these that
works of art are pure aesthetic
experiences and have nothing to do with
other aspects of life is itself a
political stay
and then serves a particular purpose
including an aesthetic purpose it
allowed these things to go on I mean
that that and it doesn't mean that that
sense I don't want the walls to go away
I didn't want all of us to be us just a
wink and and and understand that that's
not true but I want us to to know that
this is how it works yes it's true and
it goes both ways right knowing
something about the culture what was
going on helped us understand the works
and reading the works can help us
understand the present moment yeah
you're most I think your most recent
book is tyrant is that right yes and
this is about all the different ways
that Shakespeare talks about bad rulers
taking over and did you learn anything
by studying that particular angle and
shape I did I actually felt I learned
quite a lot and as often happens you
learn in the writing you learn in the
doing it's after all the basic principle
of of it's why teaching is a gratifying
act because you don't know what you
think into one says the one students and
I feel for myself you don't know what
you think before you actually sit down
and try to think it and write it and so
in the course of writing that book and
thinking about the trajectory of
Shakespeare's thinking about politics I
learned both about how he thought
catastrophic leaders could arise and I
learned about how he thought it it might
be possible under different
circumstances and he tried
experimentally as it were different
scenarios for thinking how to get rid of
a disaster of this kind short of civil
war since most often the way these
things end is through civil war and the
Shakespeare understands this to be a as
we all understand this to be a
catastrophe but how else do you get rid
of such a disaster visited upon first of
all he's interested in why would why
would sane people who are
self-interested
a society that actually after all wants
to function
more or less peacefully and prosperously
why would they allow themselves to fall
into the hands of a catastrophic leader
and then of course why when they get
into what how can they get out of it
yeah I mean what is it about Shakespeare
that makes him especially good at this
in some way you know there's been many
plays written many books written you
know about terrible rulers or about any
of those topic but he does seem to have
something interesting to say about just
about everything he does I mean I don't
have a magical I wish I did to have a
have a formula to explain this I mean I
have the usual evasions of an answer he
was a genius he was an unbelievable
genius he's a superb right I mean that
he thought about everything I mean he
had an unbelievable imagination but this
is just a way of saying I don't know I
mean that I don't know how it's how did
Mozart do what he did how did Bach do
what he did I mean that had a Jane
Austen to what she did
the people were huge species with a lot
of people in the population every once
in a while someone pops up it was just
astonishing I mean so I mean that's as
he say dumb explanation but I don't have
a smarter one I could say several other
things he came along by the accident of
his birth at a moment at which his
language was exploding with
possibilities in power he came along by
the accident of his birth at a moment in
which there was a new medium that had
not been whose resources had not been
exploited so like the first generation
that or the first generations that
figure out how to make movies or how to
make long-form television series I mean
where shortly after you start making
long-form television series someone
makes the wire you think fantastic but
it has to do with the medium being new
and available as it were to for
experiments without a tremendous
oppressive past so that's a second
explanation yeah if we could say that it
it it helped in a somewhat perverse way
that he came along at a time in which
this censorship and
he has to be thoughtful careful and
cunning Oh clever about how he wants to
to how he and his culture wants to talk
about things that are not possible to
talk about openly do you think that he
was very often trying to make trenchant
political observations but in a sneaky
way I know her yeah I do I think quite
often I think I mean and not just
trenching political observations but
transient observations about what can't
be spoken in other ways what what what
can you say about about same-sex love
that you can't say openly in the late
16th century what can you say about
about perverse family structures what
can you say about disobedience what can
you say about transgression as well as
of course more directly political a
dog's obeyed in office Shakespeare has a
character step on say you said that in
the wrong place you've gotten tremendous
trouble right and late sixteenth early
17th century but I mean you mentioned
that there's no history of progress in
the creation of these kinds of art but
there is a there are changes of style
and so forth do you see what if you
teach Shakespeare your students respond
to it differently now that decades ago
and I should quickly say there may not
be history of progress but there are
some artists who are greater than other
artists that's the premise of what we're
saying I mean that that
so there are Sanne Shing things that
that happened it's just that you don't
want to say that Shakespeare I think
it's not interesting to my things to say
that Shakespeare is a greater dramatist
and soft
then then Sophocles or I mean what does
that mean I mean that that these are
both great dramatist
but it doesn't mean that Shakespeare is
not better than the person who wrote
cracked me this not door I mean there's
tons of miserable plays that survived
from the late sixteenth early
seventeenth century so we know there are
there were bad people at this game at
their game as well as good people so and
now I've lost the train of your question
how the students respond to it all the
time I mean you know students are the
same as ice as it were and that that
they
depending on what's going on in their
lives and in their world some things
have reached them more powerfully than
other things so it's certainly the case
now that that if I teach a fellow or I
teach Hamlet the race issues or the
gender issues are registered in a
different way now than they would have
been when I was a student certain things
can be spoken
no one said when I was when I read the
Hamlet for the first time you know God
what happens what happened to a philia
what what what what why was she treated
this way what what isn't this shouldn't
we think of this as a felis tragedy or
Gertrude's tragedy that what does it
mean to to block that out and so for now
it rushes in so and likewise with with
lots of these place that Shakespeare is
very good at writing very uncomfortable
plays I once saw this BBC televised
production of Shakespeare where a fellow
was played by a white guy and there was
this long intro like sort of excusing it
or apologizing for it and so am I
correct in thinking that was just a
crazy thing to do crazy thing to do it
by white guy a crazy thing too
they made the case as far as we know a
fellow could easily have been white
that sounds very wrong well there's
several different things I'm not sure
I've I didn't have not having seen this
I'm not sure what they were up to the
play was always long long performed
until actually I think the first time
was the 19th century when it wasn't it
was performed by white actors and
various forms of blackface or a darker
face so it's certainly true that the the
play was written for Richard Burbage a
white actor and it was performed by
white actors all the way through now
they were trying to really make your IRA
all this language of the Moors and so
forth could just have been you know
southern Europeans oh yeah well it
certainly was the case that in the 19th
century particularly in in America when
the idea that this that a white woman
could fall in love with a black man
one wave of was disgusting and
outrageous from the point of view of the
racial codes of the whites one way of
arguing about the player to justify the
play was to say well he wasn't really a
black man in the sense of a sub-saharan
black man he was a more slightly swarthy
or whatever but the but not so maybe
that's why I'm not crazy it's just
happens to be racist as an argument but
and and the or oddly or odd I mean let's
by I don't know who I shouldn't accuse
the people it's a it's an uncomfortable
disturbing thing to claim depending on
what the nature of the claim was because
as they say it has an ugly history of
being invoked as a way of justifying
what is otherwise what was otherwise to
the race racist audience unjustified I
have a particular way of thinking about
you know the plays of Shakespeare's that
we now cringe at a little bit taming of
the shrew or The Merchant of Venice
where the sexism or anti-semitism seems
to me seems to us to be a little bit
different maybe than it would have been
at the time I mean there are people who
say no it's really not anti-semitic or
sexist and other people who say well
this is an illustration we should look
at it closely yeah I think I think this
is an important issue and certainly it's
important issue now because of the
nature of heightened awareness and
sensitivity in especially in
universities but I think it always
should is an important issue for
historical reasons
Minh the past but certainly for
ourselves Merchant of Venice post
Holocaust is not Merchant of Venice
before the Holocaust and that doesn't
mean it's irrelevant the Holika Holika
is irrelevant it's means as I started to
say this is our experience how can you
watch this play without thinking a
little bit about what happened in the
1930s and 40s I mean that you can't and
that's not only because we're importing
a completely irrelevant thing it's
because what happened in the 1930s and
40s is not a
unreal a
to what was already expressed in the
late 16th century which was the use of
the figure of the Jew as the as the
mortal enemy of the Christians you you
you you tell that story and enough and
powerfully enough nasty things happen
and so I don't mean that Shakespeare is
responsible for the Holocaust I just
mean that it is he's not but I think
that that the tropes of anti-semitism
that the play actually explores in a
rather profound way but not in the clean
way are very much involved in the way in
which the subsequent history as we could
say the way we started by talking about
Adam and Eve the way Eve is represented
in the in Genesis is not innocent in the
long term treatment of women I mean it's
not the whole story it's not responsible
solely for that but it's not innocence
cultures are not innocent the greatest
artists are not innocent I mean they're
they reflect the values of their world
and their time they think about them the
great ones that we care about
Shakespeare is a perfect example managed
shaykhs was not an Enlightenment artist
he's not writing to try to make people
who live in Oh to 138 people like myself
feel great about every one of their
opinions being validated in different
world the taming of the shrew is a very
disturbingly misogynistic play Merchant
of Venice is a disturbingly anti-semitic
play I have no desire to whitewash it
and say oh no they're not not a little
not at all but on the other hand because
he's a great artist he actually manages
to explore and to unsettle the very
things that he seems to be also
exploiting there's something worth
appreciating about it something worth
understanding and appreciating entering
into trying to understand how else do we
enter into them how else do we
understand this world
which continues in the case of misogyny
and anti-semitism to have a contemporary
life how do we get back into how how do
we ever enter in
to this consciousness if it's not if it
happens that it's not ours how do we
ever take some critical distance toward
it but simply denouncing it and saying
let's get rid of it imagines that
getting rid of it will just simply
eliminate the phenomenon itself it won't
yeah and Adam and Eve is a very special
case because other than Shakespeare the
Bible is probably you know in the
English language the most influential
work of literature those are probably
the top two and like you said Adam we
need as a story influenced not only how
we treat and think about women but but
many other things yeah nature for
example which should be the dominant
species is what seems to say at the
beginning of Adam and Eve but is that a
good way of thinking about what we are
in relation to the rest of the natural
world that we are somehow the the the
top banana well it happens it was
accurate we did m'as after all the text
written when humans weren't principally
responsible for the great die-off and so
forth but we would become that and they
and that text is not innocent of our
becoming in it on the other hand it
doesn't produce that I mean doesn't make
us but it helps to make us what we
became it's or at least it comes from a
common source right there so makes us
and something makes that mean yeah and
we could then because it's written in
this form as is indeed the the you know
that the transgression that is begins
with with Eve's
eating of the fruit it enables us to
start thinking about where we come from
who we are we started at this
conversation by talking about my
interest in origins and I think that
that literature even not only super old
literature like the book of Genesis but
all literature enables us to to get down
into the places that we come from and to
look and to look at them in a way that
we can't ordinary look at them because
we just we don't normally think that way
about ourselves
represent ourselves as we're doing
things unless we're very neurotic in
your book about Adam and Eve if you go
through a lot of you know how it was
interpreted over the years but tell us a
little bit because I probably many
people are not familiar with how the
story was written or you know
the the original way in which those
first couple chapters of Genesis came to
be I mean we don't know of course for
sure we don't know the story certainly
preceded the first time it was written
down it was probably written down in the
wake of the Hebrews returned from exile
in Babylon in the after I would have to
now remind myself of what the date was
when they returned under Cyrus from
their exile but the story must have have
originated long before that almost
certainly as an oral tale has the form
of an oral tale so that it wasn't
someone who sat down with a pen in hand
and wrote the thing down but probably
story that had been endlessly told and
retold in various forms
is it safe to and think that most
fiction that was written down
I shouldn't say fiction those stories
that were written down at that time did
start orally and then got rid donar were
there novelists did there did such a
thing is I mean something not novelist
but some things certainly were once once
writing cuneiform was originated what 30
about 3500 BCE I think these are we
don't know who don't know but we don't
know for sure in any case when someone
had the idea but but but in work in
Mesopotamia so someone has the idea of
actually writing things down orders for
beer shipments of things don't change
yeah I mean I say that's some I
seriously because one of the first
things that we actually have in in
Canary form our beer orders anyway it
takes place because there are now large
numbers of people living together in
work was the first city in the world
force mega city and and that meant you
were encountering people you didn't know
personally in your community so it is it
helped to spur the idea of actually
getting things somehow recorded somehow
or rather the Incas do it with those
little knots
but people in in Mesopotamia did it with
these little marks and clay and
certainly up to that point for sure the
one thing we can be absolutely sure of
is that the stories that existed existed
because they were in circulation orally
then at that point in that part of the
world and at that point somewhat later
part of a moment in which things get
written down in first in Phoenicians and
then in Greek the first stories that we
have are almost certainly stories that
are circulated orally so the Iliad in
the Odyssey our oral tales that but
written down in the first earliest
moment that the thing we talked about
with Shakespeare in the theater the
moment it which is a new technology and
often what's interesting again to return
to something we we're talking about
before the that moment of incandescent
moment of a new technology precipitates
remarkable works so Gilgamesh in
Mesopotamian culture then the Iliad and
we could say then the Bible what's
interesting about all of those three
documents we of course don't know the
relationship of the documentary survived
traces of that and the oral tale
we know from form various forms of
analysis that there's no overwhelming
likelihood that these are oral tales
before they're written down but how much
changed when they were written down to
take your novel question how much
happened when when the person lets make
his name up Ezra because some people
thought it was the Prophet Ezra who
wrote down the Bible is so very unlikely
I mean that or to take what religious
people believe Moses wrote it down or to
or when Sunna Leckie or whatever his
name was from Mesopotamia wrote it down
or though whoever we mean when we say
Homer how much was actually value added
by the writer who wrote it
we don't know there's a interesting
relation we can we can hypothesize that
between the remarkable people or Markel
geniuses who actually recorded the thing
and the stories that were circulating in
the case of the Bible it's trickier or
at least we can feel the trickiness more
manifestly because it is now unless you
are pious believer in divine inspiration
it's reasonably clear to virtually all
scholars that there are multiple texts
that are being stitched together and
that's actually what we think of Homer
as well that Homer was what was famously
called a stitcher of songs someone who
stitched these things together and the
exact an example for that and the in
Genesis is the fact that there are two
different accounts of the creation of
humans one that involves separate
creation of a male and a female and one
that seems to involve the creation of
the the two together male and female
I've heard the claim made that in Near
Eastern literature at the time the idea
of a text being completely contradictory
to itself was no big deal that was just
how we talked it always seemed weird to
me that the two stories yes naively at
odds yes well I mean people of course
for a very long time didn't think it was
naive at all I thought it was a mystery
that needed explanation and there was a
because intellectuals are good at this
and have been good at it for thousands
of years there are lots of interesting
explanations for what appears to be a
tension between the two different
accounts if you believe that the work
was dictated by an angel or by the holy
ghost to Moses then you have to and you
think it's inerrant it can't possibly
have a mistake then you can't say it's
naive or or contradictory you say that
it's a it needs explanation and needs
interpretation right and people like me
come along and say oh now I have an
interesting account were the first ten
years literally yes and but unlike Homer
let's say or I don't know enough about
Gilgamesh but there was this sort of
political cultural context right the
Hebrews were small people surrounded by
bigger peoples and the Bible had this
political
dick purpose explicitly in mind at sort
of setting an agenda of who we were and
where we came from
yes we were created by not by Marduk we
were created by Yahweh and Marduk is
nothing Marcus is a empty wind or Marduk
is the demon but Yahweh is the sole
creator of the universe so we're you
know already as it were now the Bible
doesn't say Marduk fair Yahweh yes
but the implication is that in the
beginning God
yahwah created the heavens and the earth
and that's a polemical statement it
means that the other competing gods who
claim to be doing it were claimed to
have done this OPSEU as they say Marduk
was the creator of humans or whoever
when when it Tim not and so forth
these weren't the creators as I've done
by people who aren't sort of springing
up like mushrooms out of nowhere they
are aware of who would have a world that
they're living in which they're
competing claims yeah and the is it
amazing to you that despite all of these
sort of reasons why these texts were
written they managed to come up with the
world's one of the world's great stories
or you know tell a story that has
resonance for us down through many
centuries it simultaneously amazing and
inevitable to me amazing because these
stories are so powerful and they still
reach us and in this case the story of
Adam and Eve and the in the garden with
the magical trees and the talking snake
is a story that that everyone knows
thousands years later I mean even though
it's it's a wildly implausible a story
of human origins as most stories of
human origins are nonetheless it's a
gazillion people still believe it and B
even if you don't believe it a little
New Yorker cartoon that shows two naked
people in the garden with tree everyone
knows well that means yes that that's it
that's remarkable inevitable because
that's how human beings in college
produce and can transmit their deepest
ideas that's why I'm in the business
that I'm in because the idea that this
is sort of mere decoration flowers on
the table is is it that's the naive idea
that the the the these stories
storytelling image making this is what
is at the very heart of what it is to be
a human being and to produce culture
generation after generation to transmit
it but even when I was a kid going to
Sunday School the thought that the
really bad thing was eating fruit from
the tree of knowledge rubbed me the
wrong way like that I didn't quite know
what message I was those be getting from
them is it bribe people the wrong way
2,000 years ago that's you were just you
weren't just being impious you were
responding to the story because that
that's the disturbance of the story the
stories are are if they're powerful
they're disturbing and that was and and
mystifying and and troubling that was in
in a much more modern way I as I rode
elsewhere that was Shakespeare's if you
study Shakespeare in relation to his
sources what you find is that
Shakespeare finds a powerful story he
identifies what the motive or the
explanatory principle of the story is
and he throws it away and then he starts
to work so he does that again and again
so what's an example of that well an
example of that would be Hamlet in the
in the source Shakespeare source for
Hamlet little Hamlet's father is killed
when Hamlet's a little boy it's in
Scandinavian culture where it's expected
that a son of the murder takes place in
public and is known it's expected in
this culture that the son will have to
avenge his father if the father's been
murdered the murder is known but
Hamlet's a little kid so the question is
how is he going to survive til he's old
enough to kill the person who
killed his father and the answer is that
he pretends he's insane yeah drool shits
in himself or whatever everyone in the
in the court thinks that that the little
that little Hamlet is a mentally
deficient and sort of funny at that and
so they keep him around as a kind of
harmless mascot and so he was able to
keep that going until he grows up to be
big enough to actually kill his father's
killer Shakespeare takes the basic plot
but he has Hamlet be a late adolescent
or a young man perfectly capable of
taking revenge when the ghost of his
father comes and tells him what's
happened and then Hamlet pretends to be
he says I'm gonna assume an an antic
disposition he says I'm gonna pretend
that I'm mad why I pretend you're mad it
actually is the worst possible thing to
do because it's all attention to you
yeah yourself and then it becomes the
beginning of a of a like the irritating
grain of sand and a in an oyster that
begins to produce this extraordinary
pearl and you start worrying about why
he's be everyone starts worrying in the
play why see and then we start worrying
is the audience why is he behaving this
way and so and I could show you this
again and again and King Lear in the
thell oh I mean this is how Shakespeare
works and so to go back to the the
problem of eating of from the why would
you ever tell someone not to eat of the
tree of the knowledge of good and evil
and particularly why would that be the
the principle prohibition because if you
don't know the difference between good
and evil how would you know whether to
obey the prohibition so people all I can
say is that 2,000 years ago they dug up
and in the 1940s they dug up some texts
that were buried in the sand in Egypt by
a by a so-called Gnostic group a group
that was trying to understand the the
the mysteries of the faith and the
Gnostic group thinks that the hero of
that story must be the snake or the
woman one or the other because actually
it's of course not
this is the thing that we must have and
that the god a God who tells you not to
know must be a wicked God
but then the sects that had that claim
that stamped out that got sent out yes
they lost and that's why this stuff was
buried for several thousand years
Lucretius is a very different origin
story in many ways but there's that
there's some similarities right in Adam
and Eve we get kicked out of the Garden
of the Garden of Eden in Lucretia's he's
an Adam asti's a naturalist I think it's
safe to say in the sense that he's not
the theist so there's a worry in
Lucretia soar for the readers of the
creatures that it's disenchanting that
it takes away some of the romance of the
world what what's your feeling about how
people responded to the poem actually I
I loved Lucretia sand I write about it
on my books but me we should tell the
audience what his poem is well he he was
Lucretius was a poet and philosopher
follower of the Greek philosopher
Epicurus and the atomists tradition that
Epicurus himself represented but
Lucretia is writing around 50 before the
Common Era and he writes a long latin
poem remarkably powerful and beautiful
poem and the survival of that poem is
the selfs important and surprising
because most of the texts by Epicurus by
Democritus by a loose ipis by the whole
Greek adamastor dition disappeared a
very few things survived
like literally some aphorisms some
aphorism some some accounts of what what
a piece of a letter recounts of what his
his philosophy was in a historian of an
ancient historian of philosophy who
recorded some of these things but most
of the work is gone some more recently
have been discovered by
new technology that's able to read not
by by Epicurus but some by followers of
Epicurus that's able to read that the
charred Scrolls found in the ruins of
Pompeii how many years in between
epicurus and lucretius Oh
centuries yeah yeah so so it's because
it's very full remarkably full poem
survives that we know in a rich way what
the theory is and the theory is that we
didn't begin in a magical garden and
that was made just for us and we could
eat anything we wanted and life was was
beautiful until we [ __ ] up but that we
began by accident it's not all about us
we weren't meant to be you know Matt by
God meant to be the the dominant
creatures and we didn't disobey a
commandment we began the way everything
began begins in the set of mutations he
wouldn't have said genetic mutations
atomic mutations strange sensations that
random event yeah fluctuations random
events and it's certainly the case that
that we as a species began the way all
organic species begin and a ferocious
struggle for existence and reproduction
let us say if you if somehow the
mutation led whatever thing that emerged
to be able to find food and reproduce
then that that species had a chance to
keep going
it won't go forever we're not destined
to go forever no species goes forever
because something the circumstance has
changed the environment changes we won't
get our society will will screw up in
various ways and and something else will
come along that will be more successful
at getting the available food and
reproducing filling the world but we for
a while have been though we certainly
began in in and have emerged only in a
very long difficult process of they say
random
the beginning with the kind of set of
purely random events yeah I once wrote a
little article calling him the first
quantum cosmology yes I did have this
view of the world in the fluctuations to
swerve was an important part of it but
also the you know the the the
uncompromising look at the implications
of this such as our species will end and
also our individual lives will end we
will not go to the afterlife
no no afterlife ever I mean no afterlife
because the soul is made up out of atoms
just as the body is made up of atoms
this is see Lucretia's thought the soul
was made of up out of particularly fine
atoms but that's a reasonably good
hypothesis the way we think our
consciousness is made up out of out of
very in a way very elusive neural
transmissions and once we we're gone
they'll it'll all go I mean the the way
everything goes so that the idea that
there's going to be Lucretius thought
this was good news because you didn't
have to worry that you're gonna be
pushing a rock up a hill in in Hades and
that would then roll down as soon as you
get it up to the top of the hill so he
he thought that the point about this is
that you didn't have to be afraid of
death anymore that the fear of death or
the fear of FMO is it sometimes called
fear of missing out you'll you go miss
your children and so went on that this
was you know absurd you're not gonna
miss anything because you won't be it'll
all be over and he represented this as
part of his therapy because the work
this work of philosophy was meant as a
kind of therapy to make you feel freed
from the anxieties and obsessions that
most human being spent their lives in
the grip of but but it wasn't found to
be all that effective to therapy and it
hasn't been this is our hope in our own
world what science has offered us has
been
at the very least a mixed message
therapeutically course good we managed
to extend our lifespans extraordinarily
as a result of science but deep
questions the anxieties and we only have
to look around in our political world to
understand that that the anxieties and
obsessions that have driven people for
thousands of years of our present live
and kicking now and so already when when
Luke reaches you know when when Cicero
for example contemplated the this
message from Lucretia epicureanism that
when you're dead you're dead you don't
have nothing will continue afterwards
you're not gonna have an afterlife
Cicero says in effect that's the good
news
vividly contemporary right we're still
having this debate right absolutely
absolutely have this debate with people
and you have a thesis that when the play
was read when the poem was rediscovered
it had a profound effect on European
intellectual thought eventually I don't
it don't claim that it was a overnight
sensation on the contrary it it seemed
not even so much impious so eventually
it seemed impious but at first just you
know interesting interesting for grammar
interesting for its metaphors
interesting for its imagery and so for
and so on but insofar as it was a theory
it seemed crazy crazy and the you know
crazy cosmological theory this is
rediscovered 15th century as we
discovered yes and the in the early 15th
century so it seemed in in a world that
believed precisely that that we were the
favorite creatures of a providential God
this idea that we were the result of a
set of random mutations seemed mad and
that the aspects of the theory still
seem actually hard to get hold of even
though science contemporary science
thinks that more or less their true take
the idea Lucretia says that your eyes
didn't come into being in order to
enable you to see that they were just
random mutations that and then that
turned out to be useful to be able to
see because you could you know sort of
pick up the food that you needed but the
idea that something it's still very hard
to grasp that I mean I find it hard to
grasp the idea that your eye eyes in all
of their unbelievable complexity emerged
in an evolutionary way without purpose
is that we're without clear direction
that seems impossible I was exactly what
William Paley used for his clockmaker
analogy we had to be designed to exactly
and ironically the eye seems to be one
of the easiest things for evolution to
discover it's been evolved in different
species over and over again
yeah history so well good I mean what
happens when we die you know whether
it's good to know things
how tyrants come to be I think there's
no question that these are all questions
that have not gone away I think we have
a lot to let's think about in the modern
world yes it's true all right Stephen
Greenblatt thanks so much for being on
the podcast Thank You Sean
[Music]
you
[Music]